okay time for another movie
retrospective I know what actually a lot
of people have been waiting for this one
because when I posted the little thing
on patreon where I tell people like
ahead of time what its gonna be like a
couple of you were really excited about
it like Oh waiting for this yeah so this
is ghost story from 1981 now I feel like
this one is kind of like I don't know if
it's so much forgotten um but it's kind
of like one that doesn't get brought up
a lot even when people are talking about
like 70s haunted house movies or you
know kind of ghost story type movies
from the 70s and stuff like The
Changeling and you know other things of
that nature which this movie actually
kind of resembles more like to change
the guys prize yeah I've never seen it
when I was a kid and not really liking
it well I'm you know it's the thing
about it is that I think that you would
probably okay I'm gonna say that
probably you would like it better if you
hadn't read the book although that it's
not always the case because apparently
Roger Ebert really liked the movie and
he thought the movie was better than the
book even though I think he might
possibly be high or might have been at
the time because I just like in
preparation for this review I've
actually watched the movie twice very
recently and I reread the novel so you
know that's how I do for I think I
didn't like it because I think I think
the movie was trying to appeal to an
older audience back in 1981 well yeah
like a serious slow burn movie and in 81
it wasn't what I was interested in III
was more into stuff that would ended up
being more like poltergeist and yeah you
know the more fast-paced kind of fluffy
or movies you know I mean where they
weren't so heavy this movie is kind of
heavy for me in 81
yeah I do feel like it was definitely
going for you know kind of a more
literary maybe not even literary but you
know because I feel like Peter Straub's
novel that it was based on is kind of
considered he's like a bit more litter
Stephen King and even though the book
was a best-seller and there was like a
lot of you know similar type of movies
coming out at the time but you know
maybe that was I mean it did make money
this movie but I feel like even at the
time the you know the critic reviews
were kind of like mixed or a lot of more
kind of negative like a lot of them
thought it was really not that great
talking about how I remembered we add to
it back in 81 yeah I didn't like it back
in 81 you know I mean but you know
seeing it again more recently I liked it
more yeah this is definitely one because
most I mean most of the main characters
in this are elderly yeah which you don't
see a lot so if that's why in that way
it kind of reminded me of the changeling
a little just you know just because
George C Scott was kind of at the center
of that I know that when I was a kid
though there was something about that
one that was compelling I think is
because George C Scott is just such a
damn powerful force in that movie you
know and I've grown up seeing him in
Patton and everything he just pulled me
right into that story this but that
story's a lot simpler in a way though
yeah you know I mean it's kind of linear
more literary
well it's and the thing about it is that
it's it's ironic because since I just
reread the novel I kind of want to like
talk a little bit or maybe talk a lot
about how the differences between the
novel because this is a lot different I
would call this a loose adaptation
because so much of the book was left out
and you know it just went in kind of a
different direction with things but yeah
the the the basic bones of the story is
that it's set in a town called Milburn
which I believe is a fictional town in
the movie it's in Vermont in the book it
was actually in upstate New York near
Binghamton but it doesn't really matter
in the you know context of the movie so
there's this kind of group of old guys
and they're called the chowder Society
and they are played in the movie by Fred
Astaire yes that Fred Astaire Melvyn
Douglas who was actually also in the
changeling Douglas Fairbanks Jr and John
Houseman
now these are the four main old guys and
they are just like you know they they're
very successful it's like one of them's
a lawyer one of them owns a business one
of them's like the mayor and all this
other kind of stuff but they've been
getting together and telling ghost
stories to one another and that's kind
of like how the beginning of the movie
like that's how the movie begins like
they're all like gathered at one of
them's houses they dress up in their
little dinner jackets and tuxedos and
stuff like once a month or whatever it
is and they come and they have like
cigars and brandy and do like old dude
stuff you know and they sit around
telling ghost stories and it kind of
passes around now it comes to like what
ends up happening is that one of the
members of the chowder Society
Edward Wanderley his son or one of his
sons rather David is killed in New York
City and they kind of show a scene of
this where David is like he's gotten out
of bed and there's like a naked woman in
the bed with him and he's like asking
her who are you who are you and she
keeps saying you know and then he says
what are you and she says I am you and
it's like this creepy thing and then she
turns over and she's like a corpse and
he like freaks out and he falls out the
window and dies now him dying
Spurs Edward Wanderley to call David's
twin brother Don who is also played by
Craig Watson who you probably recognize
from he was in body double and he was in
a night run up street 3 I think yeah
dream warriors yeah he was in that so he
plays both the twins so after David is
killed they ostensibly they think either
fell or committed suicide so Don gets
called back to Melbourne for the funeral
now while he's there his dad and this is
different from the book but I'll get
into that his dad Edward also ostensibly
commits suicide by jumping off a bridge
in Melbourne however the audience knows
that the reason that he fell off the
bridge was because he thought he saw the
ghost of David like walking through the
town and then he follows it and then
when he gets to the bridge he turns
around and there's this really [ __ ] up
looking
female spirit and it scares him and he
falls off the bridge
so at this point Don and the chowder
Society are kind of starting to compare
notes and it turns out that the woman
that David was in a relationship with it
made him like fall out the window had
actually prior to that been in a
relationship with Don and Don thought
there was something the matter with her
he doesn't it's a lot clearer in the
book but she's basically saying he's
basically saying that she was um I don't
think he called her a witch but it was
something like that like that he just
said there's something wrong with her
it's like when you touch her she's like
a corpse or you know she's like really
cold and she's really weird she does
like all these weird like she would
start like standing by the window in the
middle of night naked and then she
wouldn't say like creepy [ __ ] like you
know you know she would just like
sleepwalk and she would say creepy [ __ ]
to him all the time about how I'll drain
the life out of you and all this other
kind of stuff so he was understandably a
bit wigged out by this so he broke up
with her and then she sort of engineered
it so that she went to New York and got
in with his brother and that's how his
brother ended up dying now as it goes on
like I said Don and the chowder Society
start like kind of [ __ ] up [ __ ] starts
happening around the town like you know
people dying and like seeing ghosts and
stuff and it turns out that the chowder
Society killed a girl sort of
accidentally back in 1929 whose name was
Eva Galli and they were kind of like
they were all trying to dance with her
and she was like being weird and then
like they just knocked her when she like
hit her head on the thing and they
didn't want to like they were all in
their 20s so they didn't want to like
ruin their lives or whatnot so they just
like popped her ass in a car push the
car to the bottom of a pond but while
the car was going into the pond she woke
up like she is still alive and she was
like freaking out so they determined
that Eva Galli from 1929 is basically
like a revenant and this revenant
has come in back into the lives of the
chatter society through the son of
Edward Wanderley so because he knows her
as Alma Mobley it's the same woman that
was one of the things that made him like
think that was that he saw a photograph
of the three of the four of them like
back in the 20s and there's she's in the
picture and he's like yeah that's her
that was the girl that I was dating so
it is so like I said it was a couple of
them died and all this other kind of
[ __ ] but it turns out that once they
pull the car out and get the body out
everything like that like everything
works out okay in the end
now it's actually kind of a cool it's
kind of a cool movie it's pretty much
like a straight-ahead ghost story it's a
revenant story like I said you don't
find out until later on that these four
old guys like accidentally on purpose
kind of you know manslaughter discovered
it up and that you know so she's like
acting as a revenant like she comes back
as somebody else like under a different
name even though she looks the same and
it's many years later yeah it's not
creepy when they pull the car out of
there yeah and like I should say that
there's like this has like a lot of
really cool effects and I really like
it's set um you know in the wintertime
like in New England and everything's
snowy like it looks like a Christmas
card and it looks like just this pretty
little town and a lot of that was matte
paintings which I don't know if a lot of
you knew but even like I think the the
shots of like her old house like Eva
galas old house which is like a ruin and
stuff I think that was a matte painting
too which is kind of amazing which I
didn't know and that I was watching it
again today I'm like holy crap but yeah
a lot of the scenes of Melbourne and
stuff I mean they did film it I think
they filmed it in Woodstock Vermont
except for the scenes and it's supposed
to be like I said in the book it's
different but in the movie Donn was a
teacher like at a Florida College and
they actually filmed that at Stetson
University which is in DeLand which is
only a few miles from here about maybe
about 20 miles from here
so they filmed that stuff there so like
I said this is basically a straight-up
revenant story it's pretty cool-looking
they actually got a British director
John Irvin he had never really done
horror before except for maybe like I
think it was like a haunted house
like for the BBC or something so it was
like a TV movie he did stuff like action
movies he did like hamburger hill he
soldier sailor tanker spy he did like
stuff like that and then I think later
on he did like some kind of more action
movies maybe with like Schwarzenegger or
something like that I'm if I'm
remembering correctly so I don't know if
he was necessarily the best choice to do
this movie and I will say too that the
screenwriter
his name was Cohen I think and they got
this particular screenwriter because
this guy had adapted a shit-ton of
Stephen King novels he did carry from
1976 he wrote the screenplay for that he
did Tommyknockers he did the original it
you know the the one that was like the
miniseries so he wrote the screenplay
for that now he wrote the screenplay for
this and I'm gonna say that ghost story
the novel I don't know if there's any
way and I like this movie I do but it's
a different animal than the book and I'm
gonna say right here that I don't know
if you could make a successful
adaptation of this book and it be a
single movie this is one that needs a
series you know what I mean because
check it out like what they did in the
movie was they basically made it just a
traditional ghost story here's the
chowder Society here's this younger guy
they you know all this creepy [ __ ]
starts happening to them and they find
out that it's this same woman who they
killed back in 1929 and she's a revenant
basically now in the book it's a lot
more complicated than that
she exactly she's actually not she was
never a woman she's not a woman she's
essentially a shape-shifting demon um
they a couple times they make a
reference to like a Manitou like the
Native American type thing so she's
almost like an elemental spirit that has
been around forever and a couple of
things she says like hint around that
you know all the other monsters like
werewolves
vampires that kind of [ __ ] they're all
based on this same thing this thing that
she is yeah so like I said she's a
shapeshifter
so in the book it takes them way longer
to figure out that this is all the same
woman because she has like a lot more
incarnations like in the book than she
does in the movie in the movie it's
basically like hey she was a real woman
they killed her then she came back as it
goes like in another form but in it this
would have made a good Netflix yeah but
it's like a series yeah in the book she
goes under a whole bunch of different
names and it's like she always looks
different like in the movie they knew it
was the same once they saw the picture
and he's like hey that's my girlfriend
like my ex-girlfriends she looks just
like that woman from back then so yeah
what are the odds of that but this she
looks different every time sometimes
she's a little girl sometimes she's a
blonde you know sometimes she has dark
hair sometimes she has green eyes
something and the only way that you know
that it's her like the original form
that she was in I mean all this stuff
with the chowder Society like where they
accidentally killed her so if that did
happen but she wasn't a person then
either she was just that was like her
current incarnation and they killed her
and that she got pissed off so then she
kept appearing in all these other forms
now her original form like I said just
like in the movie was Eva Galli but then
later on every single incarnation she
always had the same initials Alma Mobley
and mer it and Marie
something or antibiotic amour I think
was one of her name sounds more like the
Peter Straub books that I remember read
yeah and yeah you know because the movie
didn't really seem like Peter Straub
that I read that's and I think that
that's a big criticism that a lot of
people had of it is that look I
understand if you're making you know a
two-hour movie out of a 600 page novel
yeah you got to cut a lot of [ __ ] out
but even the screenwriter on this like I
said this was the same screenwriter that
did Carrie and so he was used to
adapting these types of novels because
Straub and Steve Stephen King their
styles are very similar yeah um you know
so what like they collaborated a couple
times so like on The Talisman and stuff
I love that book I know and you can't
really tell the difference between the
two styles because the styles of read
Peter Straub is a little bit I mean he's
an American but he lived in the UK for a
long time
so he has a little more of a British
imagination kind of thing goin imagine
if they did a Netflix series of the
talisman that [ __ ] would be off the
chain that's what I would that be I
would like to see that the werewolf boy
and everything and the a nerd parallel
dimensions and drinking them drinking
the magic juice to get you that slip
over that would be amazing actually
and you think they what I mean they they
seem like they're doing that type of
thing because look they did like some
Neil Gaiman stuff like American Gods and
all that kind of a time into a series
that and a better version of the
standard I would really like to see a
good first hand and the TV version of
the stand wasn't bad it's just that it
doesn't hold up I wish you could seem so
much better now at it yeah I went back
and tried to watch it again recently and
it was kind of unwatchable it looked
really tacky yeah yeah yeah it didn't
date Mary it didn't went well at all and
you know like I said and I really like
this movie I've always liked ghost story
like I said a lot of people didn't
particularly if they really liked the
book I actually did always like this I
liked the look of it like and they even
like when it came out in 1981 it came
out like the week before Christmas
because they were really pulling for
like we wanted to come at her on
Christmas time just because of the
setting of it and it's all snowy and
they wanted it to come out so they
successfully did that and I love the
kind of you know the whole frame of it
of it being a ghost story and all these
old guys like telling ghost stories but
see the thing about it is that I think
what the movie like among many things
what the movie might have lost from the
book was that Peter Straub he actually
got the idea for this book from really
from reading Salem's Lot and in its
structure the book ghost story is very
much like Salem's Lot it's kind of about
like a small town where this
supernatural evil like comes into it and
then like the whole town kind of
implodes and there's like a spooky old
house and there's like a group of guys
that come together with like a younger
teenager to you know fight against the
evil and stuff so in that way it's very
similar
but Peter Straub has even said that like
reading Salem's Lot he's like yeah I
want to do something like that that's
like where he wanted to kind of almost
make a comment about it's almost like a
meta horror because he's got this frame
of like these old guys telling ghost
stories but then he wanted to take
actual like old literary ghost stories
like by a Nathaniel Hawthorne and you
know like Edith Wharton and stuff like
that and he wanted to kind of like
reflect them back I guess and like into
this big huge story and at the center of
it he wanted like this female demon that
was like at the heart of every single
mythic creature like you know or ghost
story so it's almost kind of like he was
he was trying to do something like that
and like I said in the book I mean you
know she's not only not a human but the
whole town is affected I mean like
dozens and dozens and dozens of people
in this town die it's not just these
four guys and the younger guy you know
what I mean like in the movie and like I
said I can see why they needed to
streamline it for you know otherwise
this movie would have been 12 hours long
to get all this stuff in there because
the book is like super complicated
there's all kind of [ __ ] going on the
thing I think that's weird about the
movie though it's weird because they cut
so much out of it but I questioned the
decision of leaving in IVA slash Alma's
little supernatural sidekicks Gregory
and Fenny you know the guy in like the
little barefoot kid now in the movie
they made them it's like oh yeah they
escaped from like a mental asylum or
something like that now in the book they
had actually been real people at one
time in the distant past but had been
kind of turned into monsters and turned
into her little henchmen so they were
not really human either like a lot of
times they were sort of like werewolves
are sort of like vampires and says they
like killed cattle they like kill people
their throats and drank their blood and
things like that but I don't know why
they left them in the movie because
since she was just a revenant like a
ghost in the movie they didn't really
need to be there
well they edited the hell out of it they
probably said well look how much got
taken out of the shining and what an
awesome movie that is we can do
something like that too and get by you
know
but you know you're talking about
Kubrick yeah yeah that's the thing a lot
big difference you know and like I said
I think that there is I do think that
this movie is a good movie I did you
know I don't think it's like the best
like creepy movie from that I do think
like the effects like particularly the
corpse effects like when they show her a
couple of times and she's all [ __ ] up
and you know looks like a bloated like
watery black it's like that looks really
awesome particularly the one seen before
edward water lee like falls off the
bridge and he's like turns around it's
like but this big horrible face and
stuff i mean the effects in it are
really good like the atmosphere of it is
really good um the woman that plays eva
/ Alma who i her name is alice krige I
guess that's how you pronounce her last
name she I think she was the Borg Queen
no and one of the Star Trek you know I
mean yeah she hasn't been in a [ __ ] ton
of stuff and I kind of feel like maybe
her being in this movie might have like
stalled her career a minute it wasn't a
bad movie though no it wasn't but it
wasn't like real well-received and it
didn't make a [ __ ] ton of money I don't
think it lost money or it might have
just broken even it was just a different
type of story it wasn't it's not the
kind of story that makes a lot of money
yeah I mean when you look even if you
were to execute this movie perfectly it
just wouldn't wouldn't be a blockbuster
yeah and I mean it's it seems really
strange to me that they thought maybe I
mean and maybe they were thinking of
like The Changeling which as far as I
know which was like a fairly big success
um that was that was a very inexpensive
I love you I think - dude the only thing
they did is build that house that's it
that's right but yeah the snow that
might have been more successful she
carried that movie
that was really - because of him and I
mean this movie I think costs a lot more
than that I think this I think goes
story costs about 35 million because
they actually they shot on location in
New York City they shot on location and
Woodstock Vermont they shot on location
in Florida they shot in Saratoga New
York and the Eva galleys old house they
built that on a set they did a bunch of
matte paintings there was a bunch of
special effects so maybe had they may be
gone The Changeling route and made it
like you know Laura budget maybe it
would have been more successful yeah but
I di I do kind of feel like I'm just
kind of conflicted because I do like the
movie as it is and like I said Alice
Krige is really good she's like really
super creepy as that character which is
kind of the way I always pictured her
when I read the book but I feel like if
you were gonna streamline it to that way
maybe they should have gone in a
different direction with it and maybe
they should have got a director that was
more versed in horror that's what I
would have done you could have you could
have taken this taking all the crazy
stuff out of that book that you were
telling about put a different tone on
like the tone of Evil Dead and and and
this and make this thing over-the-top
Ratchet it up probably done pretty well
well I don't know I just I wouldn't go
as far as doing like Evil Dead cuz it's
not like funny it's not comedic or
anything but there is a lot of crazy
[ __ ] that happens this book like I said
she's like a demon there's all kind of
there's all kind of creepy [ __ ] going on
there's cattle mutilations there's um
you know werewolf type stuff what they
did it more like fought house yeah it
could be like that like I said I think
it would be better god this is like
really hard to say because it in tone
like I said it comes it's very much like
Salem's Lot it's kind of a wide-ranging
I think it needs you know it needs the
form of like a series so it has like
more room debris or because there's like
zillions of like subplots and like all
these different characters and stuff and
it's like everything kind of relates to
one another but you don't have time to
tell everyone's story unless you our
main Salem's Lot still cool I pop yeah I
got it on I got it on DVD but I think
they have a blu-ray
version coming up wasn't that a blu-ray
steelbook that we saw I think we did see
a steelbook of that actually the other
day and fYI might be quite cool yeah
that may be that was the one we were
trying to remember the other day because
I said what was that movie that was not
a steelbook um that we wanted to buy but
yeah I mean if you haven't seen go story
and you haven't read the novel then you
will probably like it a lot more I like
it but I but they're really two
different things
I mean it's it's like the loosest of
loose adaptations they took like one it
was almost like the novel is like this
like look this little rug and they took
like one little Hank of thread and then
just like made a movie out of that and
they just left all of this other stuff
out because I mean there's like scenes
there's a whole thing about like a like
a creepy guy named dr. rabbit foot and
like his like creepy jazz band there's a
whole thing about a movie theater in
town that's playing Night of the Living
Dead over and over even though there's
nobody in there and there's like [ __ ]
coming out of the screen and there's
like there's just kind of all kind of
crazy [ __ ] and then there's like a whole
frame story about one of the characters
kind of kidnapping one of the demons
incarnations who's like a little girl
named Angie and like taking her across
the country and like how weird she is
and all this other kind of stuff so
there's just so much left out of that
out of that and I think it's kind of
like a shame I always I almost feel like
if they were gonna make the movie ghost
story like almost make it like that but
don't even like say that it's based on
the Peter Strahm know do you know what I
mean it's like chain ripples names
because the whole thing about even the
whole thing in the movie like about
everyone they left like one of the old
guys out there was actually five of them
in the book one was named Louis Benedict
and they left him out of the they left
him out of the movie he wasn't even in
there they also left out like a really
major character he was like a teenager
and his name was Peter Barnes he was one
of the ones they like helped them defeat
the demon at the end and so they left
him out and the whole thing about Edward
Wanderley who was the mayor of the town
Don and David were not his sons they
were his nephews and he barely knew that
like he only like Don only came to the
town because the chowder Society started
to suspect that something was weird
going on with the demon and after Edward
died they called him because he was a
horror writer and they thought that you
might have some insight into what was
happening because all this weird [ __ ]
started happening around sound like the
cattle mutilations and stuff I think
that was like the first thing that
started to happen so you know what I
mean so you know then you have like
these kind of like backwoods dudes being
like it they're like Martians like come
to the town and stuff like that so like
I said that the book in the I don't
think it's it's not really a difference
in tone because the book is very serious
it's kind of like literary but there's
like a lot of [ __ ] going on and I feel
like the movie tried to just take the
one little Maine little through like you
know the little thread that went through
the whole story I was like we're just
gonna make this into the movie and we're
gonna try and make it like The
Changeling or we're gonna have to we're
gonna make it like a prestige like a
horror ghost story and I think to a
small extent they succeeded I don't
think it's as good as The Changeling but
it had some really really creepy moments
like some of like I said Alice creature
was really good in it the effects were
really good at the atmosphere was cool I
really liked like the snowy like New
England town setting it was like very
claustrophobic and cool but I feel like
if you like Stephen King from that era
like you'd be like Salem's Lot and even
if you like the changeling - that's I
know that's not Stephen King but you
would probably like this if you haven't
seen it but just keep in mind that if
you've read the novel that it's really
hardly anything like that and they're
really two different things I hadn't
seen it in a long time
I didn't really remember liking it the
first time that I saw it we but then as
we saw it again yeah it's on shudder I
thought oh man her and it was it was
good I didn't have that feelings of
nostalgia for it because I didn't have a
real strong connection yeah you didn't
have a strong memory back then I mean if
I did that I probably
enjoyed it even more but I definitely
liked it better now that I did yeah I
remember liking it a lot when I was when
I was a kid prom I probably like The
Changeling and The Omen and stuff better
but I remember this one being one that I
saw a lot and that I really enjoy it and
I did I I remember really liking like
those girls like corpse things and being
creeped out by her being oh what's the
revenue she's the same woman even though
it's like 50 or 60 years whatever but
then like I think I saw the movie and
then I might have read the book like a
year or two later being like man this is
like nothing the same and then when we
decided to do this movie because it just
came up on shutter a couple weeks ago I
said you know what I have this novel
somewhere look at how sad this [ __ ]
[ __ ] looks it's like the cover fell off
yeah so I have this I have the novel
back in the days to see this cover
everywhere book so it did well that
behind cool was filled with those back
we were that's why they wanted to make a
movie out of it because like I said they
were like the horror movies were doing
like big business back then it was like
chi-ching chi-ching less official in the
late 70s and like I said even ones with
like an older protagonist or like more
serious ghost stories and stuff we're
still like making Bank and it was a
different era I mean yeah you may you
might have been a high school kid it
didn't do your homework but you sure as
hell read those things oh hell yeah I
read all kinds of I did you well that's
a great all the time but you know I
think readings kinda like a lost art I
don't think kids really do it they might
read tablet yeah well what do people
read like a ebooks and stuff like that
because it's just easier than laser one
went around yeah the same and I was the
same like when I was in high school man
[ __ ] I was brave Peter strong but I read
Clive Barker and Stephen King and I had
all that [ __ ] I got it all out of the
library and I was constantly reading
something yeah but yeah so I feel like
since there were so many bestsellers and
ghost story was like a humungous
bestseller so you know there were like I
think they paid a million dollars like
for the rights to make it into a movie
and then I'm not gonna say they whipped
it cuz it's a good movie but it's really
not an adaptation of the book in any
meaningful sense it's it's really not
really the same at all but it's a good
movie on its own merits and as I said I
think probably the that actresses
performance is my
favorite part of it just because she's
so creepy and otherworldly which i think
is really good because that's kind of
what she was like in the in the book and
also and the corpse effects are pretty
cool and I like how they just kind of
threw that in it and I love how like
before old guys are in this this is
mostly this is their last movies because
most of them die I think actually Melvyn
Douglas died before this even came out
but it's kind of nice to see a movie
with like four old codgers it's like the
big characters instead of like 20 year
old but you know I think Fred Astaire
was probably the best in this out of all
the out of all the old guys and like I
said Melvin Douglas was in The
Changeling as well if I feel like he was
in another horror movie - around this
time period but I can't reward it is oh
well but anyway um so yeah if you
haven't seen ghost story this sort of
kind of adaptation of the Peter Straub
novel it's from 1981 you should check it
out you might enjoy it who knows and
also I recommend the book and I
recommend most the Peter Straub the
other books - and I see why they don't
make a lot of I think I was complaining
the other day it's like why don't they
make a lot of adaptations of Peter
Strauss work but then when I was reading
this again I was like oh yeah that's why
this is too hard to make a movie I
wouldn't even know where to start
actually in this one and I kind of
admire anybody taking a swing at it but
you know you're gonna have to like pare
it way the [ __ ] down like take we like
to take pretty much five hundred and
fifty pages [ __ ] and just like
concentrate on that
alright so that'll do it for this
episode of the movie retrospective
remember if you liked the show like
share subscribe on all your social media
if you would like to financially support
the show you can go to our patreon page
patreon.com/lenguin
if you would like to do so and check out
our shirts yep we may we I'm prayin just
hot off the screen print' yeah press so
yeah I put it I put a video up for the
patrons and I put it on the 13 o'clock
Facebook they ship in a few days so in a
couple of days all you $20 not patrons
plus the person
that one the drawing will be getting
your t-shirts yeah right so we will see
you next time bye